can't do can't do a preview of what's
going on with the Vikings without a
little cameo for my buddy Paul out on
the voice of the Vikings but you know
the Vikings last year the expectations
were ridiculously high they get to the
final four they swap out Case Keenum for
Kirk Cousins hey everything's gonna be
fine we make the next step this year
that didn't happen for the Minnesota
Vikings they didn't even make it to the
playoffs so that they they had a very
disappointing campaign Chris and and the
pressure is on this team now that you
know and you know there's only so much
you can do in the offseason when you are
strapped for cap space they found a way
to keep Anthony Bar they've kept Kyle
Rudolph around for now they're talking
to him about an extension they have that
nucleus of great players we're all
making a lot of money but but can they
hold it together do they have the depth
necessary where their young talents step
up and can they win games in primetime
they got five this year even though they
make the playoffs last year they still
have five prime time games and last year
they showed they were not ready for that
stage and Kirk Cousins has shown us
throughout most of his career he's not
ready for that stage whether it's fair
or not that's the reality perception is
reality and he's got to change the
reality and the perception in 2019 yeah
I hear ya all together there I mean
you're right it is on Kirk Cousins I
mean you said it the Minnesota Vikings
are still a very dangerous football team
they got star power they're very
top-heavy roster and I think you know
the one thing you said there that I
still questioned about Minnesota is the
depth of their football team like we saw
last year guys got injured and they had
a hard time kind of holding together
especially on the offensive line part
you know hey they got a little depth
they're drafting Garrett Bradbury out of
North Carolina State at a play center
he's an awesome football player he is
certainly gonna help out that football
team whether he plays center guard early
on however it may be I expect him to be
the center you know they got a guy like
Josh Klein to add a little depth to the
offensive line as well
he can play guard and move around in
that interior spot but yeah overall they
just need to say healthy up front that's
the big thing hey you get your two of
Dalvin cook I expect him to even be
better than he was before but the big
question and on the offensive side of
the ball too is hey
Kevin's defense keys taken over his
offense coordinator what's with him and
the help of Gary Kubiak what's this
offense going to look like that would be
my big question right off the bat I
would expect they're gonna get back to
running the football a little bit what
we heard from Mike Zimmer last year that
he was disappointed why they fired John
D filippo and then you go over the
defense yeah you get Anthony barback
great
you lost Sheldon Richardson okay so they
need a guy like Jalen Holmes their
second round pick from two years ago out
of Ohio State to probably jump in there
and and show himself as a defensive
tackle starter there Xavier Rhodes right
Mike he's got to show up better and play
like one of the better corners in
football he was a letdown last year so
you know Everson Griffin issue last year
there was a lot of things that went on
last year that led to the Minnesota
meltdown let's say and one thing that
that I don't think gets enough attention
the passing of Tony Sparano the
offensive line yeah one of the guys who
have a conscience for coach Mike Zimmer
would say the things that need to be
said sometimes to a very headstrong and
opinionated head coach like Zimmer is
and that's fine a lot of coaches are
that way but you need to have voices to
balance you out and Sparano was one of
those voices that happened so close in
time to the start a training camp I
don't think they ever recovered from
that now they have a goobie Gary Kubiak
on board to help with that offense that
has kind of energized the vibe on that
side of the ball the the zone blocking
draft right the the players specifically
for that moving pad off line to guard
and putting first rounded area at burry
its center that that's all going to help
the mobile blockers the reshaping the
offensive line finding a running game
again getting more out of Dalvin cook
this year one full year removed from his
torn ACL that's all gonna make it easier
for Kirk Cousins to throw the ball I
think last year there was so much of a
focus on justifying the investment in
cousins in John D filippo auditioning to
be a head coach somewhere also traveling
up a lot of yes plays instead of running
plays yeah and the Vikings got off track
early and they never could sustain
momentum and they still ended up with a
winning record right they just weren't
good enough to get to the postseason no
yeah I mean Mike you made all the points
I wanted to say you're right I mean
that's exactly what happened last year
you kind of you know talked about the
wormhole they went down and then add on
to it they were really banged up on the
offensive line and
aspect or that part of their football
team to where yeah they were not patient
with the run game and when they did try
to stay patient with the run game they
weren't a very effective at blowing
people off the line of scrimmage and
being effective there so that's the one
thing I look forward to and I think Mike
Zimmer is gonna really like that aspect
of having Garrett Gary Kubiak a part of
that offensive staff Rick Dennison who's
been with Gary Kubiak
the run game I think will be better than
we've seen in years past in Minnesota I
mean I I do think it's got potential
with a guy like Dalvin cook and some of
the moves they made in the offensive
line - yeah get closer back to the form
of what we saw the year they went to the
final four which I believe that year
they were a top ten maybe the six best
rushing offense in football but that
will make life easier on Kirk Cousins
it's gonna make life easier on digs in
Thielen last year they did they became
what too one-dimensional I didn't really
ever go into games thinking they were
gonna be able to run the ball
effectively so that hurt Kirk Cousins
and and the the passing game in general
and it's really not the style of
football that Minnesota wants to play
and it's Dalvin cook this year with
Alexander Madison the rookie from Boise
State who arrived here around three
latavius Murray is gone and looked at
Avis Murray had his moments and like you
said the Vikings had a very good rushing
offense in 2017 when Cooke was injured
week four and it was Murray the rest of
the way but Murray's always been a guy
he's got that high center of gravity and
he just you know he either hits the hole
or he doesn't if he hits the hole he
gains four or five yards otherwise he's
flat on his back and I just don't think
he's been the guy that they really need
to energize the running game we'll see
what the rookie does but the other side
of the coin - and I criticize the
Vikings all the time for their poor
performances last year in primetime the
way the schedule is structured this year
and and I don't think we've touched on
this but I just noticed this now yes
they have five prime time games but the
first one isn't until week eight they
got seven games that aren't primetime
the closest that come is a 425 p.m.
Eastern Time kickoff at Chicago week
four that's the big game in the first
seven but there isn't a primetime game
until they host Washington week eight on
a Thursday night I'll tell you what by
the time they get to the tough prime
time game yeah the game
at Dallas the Monday night game at
Seattle the night game at LA against the
Chargers the night game at home against
the Packers two days before Christmas
will already know whether or not they're
worth a crap Bay I mean they don't have
a bunch of primetime games to trip them
up as they develop who they are they've
got half of a season almost to show us
who they are before they get into those
night games and by then it won't matter
that they're night games we'll know
whether they're good or whether they're
not good yeah no you're right we will
and you know again I think it gets a
little overblown with the Kirk Cousins
primetime thing I know you're right
perception is reality is gonna have to
perform on those stages and their team's
gonna have to win for people to back off
of that I get it you know I guess the
big thing is with Minnesota too we got
to take into account like hey the NFC
North legit this year there is you know
been some drastic changes and of course
there's some talents and rosters where
do you think they're gonna end up in the
NFC North ultimately do you think
they're gonna place higher than the
Bears and the Packers when all said and
done I think they're gonna place higher
than one of those two teams I just don't
know which one yet I think they're gonna
finish second or higher okay in the
division and I think they will get to
the playoffs this year at a minimum as a
wildcard but you know they're getting
the Packers in Green Bay at the perfect
time yeah too right
very early in the Matt Lafleur
experience as head coach of the team
right you don't have to worry about
whether two years in a row that they've
gone to Green Bay week two and I think
that's going to help them surpass the
Packers the question is what kind of a
letdown will we see from the Bears the
Bears had changes they got a new
defensive coordinator you know that time
to figure out what Matt naggy and Mitch
true Biscay is doing with that offense I
think the Vikings could win that
division peoples at all time oh you're
too hard on the Vikings look folks I
think they can win the division this
year and the high end analytics every
other year the Vikings make it to the
playoffs that's good enough for me this
is a playoff year for the Vikings the
question is is it wildcard or is it a
special kind of season where they win
the division and they forced some people
to come to Minnesota for the postseason
because we know that team far more
likely to advance when they're playing
their postseason games at home yeah yeah
yeah yes they are I mean that's a
dangerous place to play the Vikings are
talented there's no denying that I mean
you certainly can make an argument and
they I I could if you told me the
Vikings win the NFC No
earth in December I wouldn't go oh my
gosh I can't believe that happened I
would have never imagined it would have
happened before the season started I
mean I get it there's too many big-time
football players but I don't think I can
pick them to win the division I don't
think I can pick them to finish any
better than then third really when I
really look at it I think if you made me
nail down the NFC North right now you
said Chris I want to have your rankings
right now for May in May I would go okay
I'm still gonna make the Chicago Bears
king of the NFC North I'm gonna make the
Packers in Green Bay second and I think
Minnesota overall is gonna place third
like a highly competitive third maybe a
eight and eight kind of nine and seven
type of third-place but I don't know I
just don't see a big-time playoff run
from this football team Vegas says nine
wins for the Vikings are you over are
you under it sounds like you may say
push I'm right around that push area
yeah I mean I don't worry so if I had to
pick over or under without the push I
would probably go under I'm gonna say
eight and eight somewhere right around
there but yeah I think if you made me
actually or yeah push is probably where
I want to go but I don't want to be a
wimp and kick you know pick push right
now I think they're gonna finish at
least second in the division okay look I
I the Packers have to prove it to me and
and I'm the guy that's picked the
Packers to be the NFC representative in
the Super Bowl for the last seven years
and I think first year with a head coach
I like what they're doing I like the
changes but I just I think it's not
gonna be as easy as we think and it is
gonna take some time and we know that
the guy who's the middle of it all has a
tendency to maybe get a little
frustrated how how is he gonna react to
these changes especially when they're
out there in games that count and maybe
things aren't working because people
aren't on the same page and it's it's a
work in progress he hasn't had to deal
with that ever really society came his
starter he's had the same head coach his
entire career all right we're gonna take
a break but we're not done with our
offseason examinations because we're
trying to get them all done by the end
of the week we're gonna do a third one
today whoa look at the Pittsburgh
Steelers when this edition of pro
football talk live continues right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports